que nous menons à la demande du
président Gérard
Larcher sur la crise du logement et que
nous conduisons de façon
transpartisane comme on a souvent
l'occasion de le faire ici au Sénat
trois trois sénatrices qui sont toutes
les trois particulièrement engagées sur
le domaine du logement Vivien Artigalas
sénatrice socialiste des Hautes Pyrénées
Amel gaker sénatriste centriste du pas
decalé et moi-même sénatrice des Alpes
Maritimes et présidente de la commission
des affaires économiques donc nous avons
commencé nos auditions à la mi décembre
nous envisageons de rendre notre rapport
à la fin du mois de mars euh et donc euh
une fois que le rapport sera rendu euh
on a deux possibilités à tout le moins
première chose c'est d'en faire une PPL
avec une partie euh des propositions euh
et des mesures que nous aurons
préconisées dans le cadre de CEPP
rapport au travers des différentes
auditions au sens très large que nous
avons mené et que nous continuerons à
mener ou initialement mais comme on sait
plus très bien ce qu'il en est puisque
d'une part il y a plus de ministre du
Logement encore et toujours pour l'heure
alors on en attend un éminemment sous
peu mais pour l'instant il y en a
toujours pas et surtout quand on a
commencé cette mission d'information et
pour avoir auditionner euh l'ancien
futur ex je sais plus comment on doit
dire ministre du logement à chaque fois
qu'on lui posait une question qui avait
trait au au logement et plus
particulièrement aussi à la crise du
logement il renvoyait tout cela à un
grand projet de loi dont il annoncé le
calendrier pour le mois d'avril nous
étions déjà assez sceptiques à l'époque
sur la tenue du 10 calendrier et
aujourd'hui on se dit que voilà ce grand
projet de loi logement je ne sais pas en
tout cas s'il sera présenté et dans quel
délai le sera-t-il donc voilà où on en
est au niveau niveau de nos travaux mais
en tout cas nous on déclinera à tout le
moins tout ou parti des mesures qui
relèvent du domaine législatif très
certainement dans le cadre d'une
proposition de loi qui après pourra
servir à un autre véhicule législatif en
tout cas nous l'espérons parce que il y
a urgence à agir donc nous sommes
vraiment très heureux de de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui pour que vous
puissiez nous apporter votre témoignage
votre analyse et surtout vos
propositions face à la crise actuelle et
je sais voilà pour avoir échanger avec
vous mais avoir aussi lu des interviews
que vous avez pu donner à la presse et
en particulier un qui avait quand même
assez décoiffé aux échos où justement
voilà vous disiez il faut bien se rendre
compte qu'il n'y a plus d'argent ou en
tout cas que le gouvernement ne voudra
plus mettre d'argent sur le secteur du
logement et qu'il faut aujourd'hui voilà
trouver des des des mesures qui soient
temps soit peu disruptives mais c'est ce
que nous attendons aussi pour peut-être
un peu changer de de logiciel et
apporter des réponses à cette crise du
logement donc je rappellerai que vous
avez été ministre du Logement de 2009 à
2012 soit après le déclenchement de la
crise des subprimes en 2008 vous êtes
également maire de Chalon en Champagne
depuis 2014 et enfin vous menez en
parallèle une carrière dans le secteur
privé immobilier puisque après avoir été
président du directoire d'in le la
filiale d'Action Logement chargé du
dévelop ement du logement intermédiaire
et je pense qu'on va en reparler ne
serait-ce que en se référant aux
quelques annonces qu'a fait le premier
ministre toute petite dans sa
déclaration de politique générale vous
êtes depuis 2022 président du promoteur
et aménageur emriig qui est actif sur
l'ensemble du secteur immobilier sans
corsoter votre expression que je
souhaite la plus libre possible pour
nous aider à avancer et justement sortir
le logement de son carcan de son son
marasme et d'un certain immobilisme il
me semble que la triple expérience que
je viens de rappeler pourrait vous
amener à nous dire comment d'ors et déjà
vous appréciez les petites mesures ou
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
actuel face à la crise de l'immobilier
et plus directement ce qui a pu être
annoncé dans le discours de politique
générale de Gabriel hatal par ailleurs
beaucoup de promoteurs se plaignent de
maire qui ne signent plus de permis de
construire ou qui n'accorde des
autorisations que très inférieures aux
possibilités qui sont offertes par le
Plan Local d'Urbanisme qu'en pensez-vous
comment peut don peut-on débloquer les
choses et puis enfin donc le premier
ministre a parlé de logement locatif
intermédiaire pour les classes moyennes
et de l'intégrer dans les cotas SRU
alors après j'ai vu intégrer pour
partiese donc je sais pas très bien
comment il envisage de de faire cela je
voudrais bien sûr recueillir votre avis
les classes moyennes ne sont-elles pas
plus en demande d'accession à la
propriété et n'y a-t-il pas par ailleurs
un grand besoin de logements très
sociaux enfin d'une façon très laconique
le Premier ministre a évoqué aussi une
simplification en tant que maire et
acteur de ce secteur comment voyez-vous
les choses voilà ce sont quelquesunes
des questions que nous avons en tête et
sur lesquel nous sommes particulièrement
intéressés de pouvoir en débattre avec
vous je vais d'ors et déjà vous laisser
la parole pour le temps que vous
souhaiterez et j'indique que notre
audition fait l'objet d'une
retransmission en vidéo en direct et à
la demande sur le site internet et sur
les réseaux sociaux du Sénat voilà
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse la
parole bien volontiers merci Madame la
la présidente mesdames les les
sénatrices très heureux de me retrouver
dans cette configuration euh c'est assez
amusant après quelques années de revenir
sur ces euh sur ces bancs et donc très
très heureux de vous retrouver pour
cette cette belle mission
si on essaie peut-être de se placer dans
des perspectives de de long
terme on voit que sur les 20 ans 30 ans
qui viennent on a probablement deux
grands enjeux en matière de politique du
logement il y en a 50 mais je veux en
sortir deux comme me semblant plus
prioritaire que d'autres parce que vous
le verrez évidemment
contradictoire on doit tout d'abord
avoir une politique du logement ou une
politique de l'immobilier comme toutes
les politique publique qui soit conforme
à nos engagements et au choix que nous
avons fait en matière de changement
climatique autrement dit les politiques
immobilières doivent évidemment
j'enfonce les portes ouvertes s'engager
durablement vers une politique qui
limite le changement
climatique deuxième élément on doit
avoir une politique qui réponde aux
enjeux
démographiques certes on a semble-t-il
besoin de se réarmer sur le plan
démographique il n'en demeure pas moins
contentre le vieillissement de la
population élément souvent oublié mais
quand je vivais jusqu'à 60 ans ben
j'avais besoin d'un logement jusqu'à 60
ans quand j'en ai quand je vis jusqu'à
80 ben j'en ai besoin mécaniquement
jusqu'à 80 plus le dcerment familial
plus les progressions naturelles qui
existent on a mécaniquement besoin de
plus de mètres Carr de mè Carr de
théâtre de M Carr de logement de mè Carr
de garage de M Carr de ce que vous
voulez mais si j'ai une démographie
positive globalement j'ai besoin de plus
de mètes Carr et si je mets les deux en
parallèle changement climatique
démographie je me retou dans une
contradiction absolue puisque le
changement démographique climatique
pardon doit nous conduire à économiser
du foncier et du
béton par contre les évolutions
démographiques que nous connaissons
nécessitent plus d'immobilier donc on a
une contradiction fondamentale si j'en
tire quelques conséquences mais qui sont
me semble-t-il assez assez lourdes c'est
que c'est tous nos paradigmes qui
doivent évoluer et le zan est
probablement la réforme la plus
importante que subira le secteur
immobilier depuis je sais pas combien de
temps mais en tout cas depuis très
longtemps
pourquoi j'imagine que à Nice comme à
béune comme dans les Pyrénées Orientales
si j'ai bien retenu votre département
madame la sinatrice haute pyrénée voilà
j'ai fait l'erreur qu'il ne fallait pas
faire haute pyrénée j'en suis confus
si vous prenez les cartes de Nice depuis
2000 an j'imagine que comme toutes les
villes de France et Navar j'imagine on a
fait l'exposition comme partout on a
d'abord une petite tâche puis une grosse
tche puis une très grosse tâche et bref
on a ce qu'on appelle de l'étalement
urbain et on a un phénomène
universel depuis que l'homme est l'homme
le développement urbain se fait à
l'horizontale et les
villes
progresse s'agrandisse je ne sais pas
quel terme utiliser à l'horizontale en
grignotant des espaces naturels la lois
zan met un stop à ça et donc on va
devoir faire une révolution culturelle
totale puisqueà partir du moment où le
zan est objectivement l'un des meilleurs
outils pour lutter contre le changement
climatique parce que c'est l'étalement
urbain qui génère si mes chiffres sont
exacts 42 % des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre si effectivement on doit
arrêter la progression urbaine à plat il
va falloir la faire en
3D un peu en dessous beaucoup au-dessus
et donc Chang changer pardon d'un
développement urbain aujourd'hui
historiquement depuis 2000 ans depuis
10000 an à l'horizontale vert verticale
3D c'est un changement qui peut paraître
basique à prononcer comme tel parce que
la verticalité la descente la densité et
cetera et cetera on en parle depuis
effectivement très très très très
longtemps mais je veux simplement le
mettre moi en rapport historique en
disant qu'on est à contreculture
complète de ce que nous avons fait
depuis des centaines d'années partout
dans le monde partout dans le monde et
évidemment en France comme ailleurs
j'insiste vraiment lourdement sur cette
apparente contradiction qui ne peut
trouver de solution entre le
démographique et le climatique que dans
le développement
vertical c'est basique mais je pense
qu'il est absolument indispensable de le
répéter
parce que dès qu'on dit verticalité
évidemment on a les élus locaux
porte-parole de leurs habitants qui
effectivement se crispe par rapport à ça
et donc on a besoin évidemment de
compréhension de pédagogie tout ce qu'on
veut par rapport à à ce pointl mais je
voulais évidemment
l'évoquer peut-être un second point en
conséquence plus que jamais à la lumière
de cette horizontalité versus
verticalité le
foncier va
devenir la matière première stratégique
à toute construction immobilière c'est
déjà le cas c'est déjà notre matière
première principale quel que soi nos
fonctions dans les secteurs de
l'immobilier mais pour faire une école
j'ai besoin de terrain pour faire un
théâtre j'ai besoin de terrain pour
faire un logement j'ai besoin de terrain
pour faire du bureau j'ai besoin de
terrain et même pour faire du numérique
j'ai besoin de poser un data center donc
j'ai besoin de foncier mais ça va plus
loin que ça aujourd'hui le foncier est
une matière première partagée parce que
c'est par le foncier que je vais nourrir
la population c'est par le foncier que
je vais pouvoir lutter contre le
changement climatique si je mets des
forêts en faisant la captation de
carbone dans le sol et c'est par le
foncier que je ferai de l'immobilier
bref c'est une matière indice première
absolument indispensable à toutes les
formes de vie et cette matière première
aujourd'hui elle est
sous-analysée elle est
sousprégée et elle est excessivement mal
l'utiliser juste un mot par rapport à ce
que vous venez d'évoquer madame la
Présidente dans votre introduction sur
les M les PC le PLU quand on gâche 1 m
carré de terrain parce qu'on ne va pas
au PLU on paume ce mètre carré de
foncier pendant 100 ans la durée de vie
moyenne d'un bâtiment c'est 80 on le
paume pendant 80 ans c'est pas une
fiscalité si on s'est planté de
fiscalité on la change à la prochaine
loi de finance là je construis quelque
chose je m'en prend pour 80 ans et donc
dès qu'on gaspille cette matière
première dès qu'on utilise très mal
cette matière première indispensable à
toutes les constructions indispensable à
l'agriculture indispensable à toutes les
formes de vie ce gâi là est me
semble-t-il plus dramatique que bien
d'autres et donc il faut gérer le
foncier de façon beaucoup plus cohérente
qu'on le fait aujourd'hui pour arrêter
de le sous-utiliser de le mal utiliser
et bien évidemment tout ça devrait nous
conduire à un moment autre avoir des
politiques foncières que nous n'avons
pas le foncier est aujourd'hui cassé
entre plein d'utilisateurs et plein de
ministères responsables il y a pas de
politique de stratégie foncière en tant
que T encore avec ses différents usages
il n'y en a pas c'est absolument
indispensable pour des politiques de
très long terme encore parce que c'est
la matière première indispensable au
métiers que nous exerçons et là encore
pas simplement à nos métiers mais à
plein d'autres c'était peut-être deuxème
point un peu générique que je voulais
évoquer pour essayer de tracer aussi des
perspectives entre guillemets d'un peu
d'un peu long terme trème élément
peut-être qui répond aussi à une partie
de vos vos
questions attirer votre attention sur le
fait
que nous sommes dans une matière dont
chacun nous dit qu'elle est complexe
dont chacun nous dit qu'elle est
difficile d'accès don chacun nous dit
qu'elle est très normée c'est une
réalité j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que c'est une le logement ou
l'immobilier au sens large et d'ailleurs
c'est assez intéressant de voir de dire
qu'il y a énormément de réglementation
sur la partie logement de l'immobilier
sur la partie tertiaire notamment bureau
il y a quasiment rien ça c'est
intéressant de voir l'écart entre les
deux bon mais parenthèse fermé loin de
moi l'idée de vous suggérer de normer le
tertièire c'était pas ça le le
sous-entendu qui était le mien bien
évidemment donc c'est une matière c'est
une matière qui est excessivement
réglementée et vous l'avez évoqué madame
la
[Musique]
Présidente nous sommes ici dans une
ancin parlementaire j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que c'est une
matière qui est principalement
législative et très pas réglementaire
dans ma vie il se trouve que dans des
fonctions d'avant j'ai travaillé
principalement sur deux sujets
l'éducation nationale et le logement
éducation nationale zéro loi on peut
tout faire par le règlementaire tout on
fait une loi tous les 5 ans parce que
politiquement on a besoin d'affirmer
quelque chose mais c'est des lois qui
sont vide de norme le logement c'est
exactement l'inverse tout est législatif
j'ai le souvenir d'avoir dû déposer
comme député un amendement à la demande
de chez plusi euh pour pouvoir faire
obtenir aux directeurs généraux d'OP un
ticket restant pourquoi parce que la R
rération des directeurs généraux deop
étant législative mécaniquement toutes
les rémunérations accessoires doivent
être législatives c'est anecdotique mais
très symbolique de ce qu'est aujourd'hui
cette matière elle est sur législative
et de mon point de vue si on veut
aboutir à un moment à de la
simplification il faudrait faire une loi
de
déclassement c'est-à-dire faire un peu
mieux respecter les articles 34 et 37 de
notre chère Constitution qui définit qui
est une matière législative et qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui ressort de la loi
d'une matière règlementaire pardon de
normes réglementair qui dépendent du
décret la première des simplification à
la loi ce qui appartient à la loi au
règlement ce qui appartient au règlement
parce que vous le savez comme moi
mesames les céatrice quand vous rentrez
au Parlement avec un texte de 150
articles sur le logement vous en sortez
avec 300 et vous avez effectivement un
pavé normatif de plus parce que tout
passe par la loi or la loi se change
beaucoup plus difficilement que le
règlement ce qui est normal et c'est
pour ça que la loi do être stratégique
et renvoyer évidemment au décret ce qui
doit évoluer plus rapidement si vous
voulez la simplification ça passe
obligatoirement me semble-t-il d'abord
et avant tout par une loi de
déclassement parce que ce n'est
qu'en rerégulant ce qui appartient à la
loi ce qui appartient au règlement qu'on
pourra me semble-t-il dénormer plus
facilement les choses parce que vous le
savez comme moi au-delà du 150 article
qui devient 300 si effectivement on doit
faire de la simplifit par la
loi on y arrivera jamais parce que la
simplification c'est comme les niches
fiscales cher un ancien rapporteur
général du budget il y a beaucoup de
chien dedans qui protège la niche en
question c'est exactement la même chose
pour les règlements pour la les normes
donc j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que de mon point de vue la première
des simplifications c'est l'article 34
et l'article 37 de la Constitution à
respecter sur le le
logement peut-être après c quelques
généralités deux trois points évidemment
sur la la crise actuelle et des
préconisations qu'on pourrait imaginer
alors je parle bien de la crise
actuelle qui se surajoute à un secteur
en crise depuis je sa pas combien de
temps je ne sais même plus si le terme
crise est appropriée plus de logement
puisque ça fait 30 ans 40 ans j'en sais
rien qu'on nous parle de crise du
logement et ça fait globalement depuis
le Milu des années 70 que nous sommes
dans un secteur
sous-offreur par rapport au besoins la
dernière grande réforme en la matière
c'est celle de Raymond bar 6 souir sonb
en 76 ou 77 qui avait distingué ce qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui les a de la pierre
et les a de la personne nous avions fini
un cycle de production on avait à peu
près équilibrer les choses au milieu des
années 70 et Raymond bar a fait stopper
les aides de la pierre donc les a de la
production pour basculer sur les aides à
la personne et donc on a basculé d'une
politique quelque part de l'offre vers
une politique de soutien à la demande
via les aides à la personne ça
correspondait parfaitement à l'époque on
avait plus besoin de construire au m
années 70 on avait fait à peu près ce
qu'il fallait et donc on a basculé sur
un soutien à la demande via notamment la
création des aPL qui était complètement
cohérente avec les besoins du moment
sauf qu'on est resté sur ce schéma
depuis 77 or les besoins aujourd'hui de
production non'ont plus rien à voir avec
ceux que nous avions dans le passé donc
si on prend depuis là encore un assez
long terme derrière nous la raison
principale de la crise la raison
principale de la crise structurelle que
connaî ce secteur vous la connaissez
aussi bien que moi c'est un déséquilibre
depuis qui perdure entre l'offre et la
demande et tant qu'on aura une politique
sousœufreuse en matière de production de
logement en matière de logement donc bah
la conséquence ce sera mécaniquement des
prix qui qui montent il y a pas d'autres
mécanisme de ce point de vuelà la
politique du logement est très
simple la politique du logement sur des
très longs termes ne dépend que d'un
seul facteur qui ne sont pas les taux
d'intérêt qui ne sont pas je sais pas
quoi je sais pas quoi je sais pas quoi
qui dépend de la démographie j'ai plus
de monde j'ai besoin de plus de mètres
carrés j'ai moins de monde j'ai besoin
de moins de m carré vous avez cité
madame la la présidente le fait que
j'étais maire de Chalom en Champagne
j'ai cette chance extraordinaire de
travailler exclusivement sur la Côte
d'Azur sur le plan professionnel ou sur
l'île-de- France donc des zones ultra
tendues et d'être m dans du ultra
détendu bah produire chez moi du
logement n'a aucun sens et il faut
surtout pas le faire parce que j'ai pas
de besoin et j'ai pas besoin de long de
produire des mètres carrés tout
simplement parce qu'ach chal en
Champagne en 1975 il y avait 50000
habitants 55000 pour être précis et
qu'aujourd'hui on est 45000 donc j'ai
pas besoin de produire des mètres carrés
j'ai besoin de réhabiliter j'ai besoin
de reconfigurer j'ai besoin de
réaménager mais j'ai pas besoin de
mettre carré supplémentaire parce que
j'ai une démographie négative c'est
exactement l'inverse dans les
territoires dit tendus où là on a un
besoin de production massif tout
simplement parce qu'il y a une
démographie positive la relation de
causalité de ce point de vue-là pour
ceux qui nous disent que cette matière
est complexe elle a des ressorts
fondamentaux qui sont assez simples la
démographie et le vecteur d'ajustement
principal du secteur du secteur de
l'immobilier j'en arrive à donc la crise
sousasscante que nous connaissons depuis
30 ans elle estcalé la crise actuelle
c'est principalement deux
facteurs
évidemment la montée des taux et le plus
que le niveau des taux c'est la rapidité
de la montée des taux
bon on a les deux facteurs évidemment
son son le numérur en tant que tel mais
c'est surtout la rapidité avec laquel on
a pris quatre pointau en l'espace de
d'un an deuxième élément c'est les
resserrements le resserrement au même
moment des conditions de
crédit donc les taux le resserrement du
crédit puisque c'est à peu près au même
moment que sous la direction du Haut
Comité pour la stabilité financière les
taux pardon les taux les conditions de
crédit ont été resserées sur la duration
d'un emprunt sur le niveau des emprunts
enfin et cetera vous connaissez le
schéma en même temps que moi aussi bien
que moi donc les deux sont arrivés en
même temps et les deux ont totalement
grippé le système et la plupart des
acheteurs ont disparu du marché nous
avons sur le marché du logement quatre
acheteurs classique pour un
promoteur le particulier pour se loger
lui-même donc le futur propriétaire
occupant l'accédent à la propriété ou le
second
accédent deuxème acheteur le particulier
mais cette fois-ci comme investisseur
soit so via un produit type le Pinel
soit via autre chose l'institutionnel
privé grande banque grand grande
compagnie d'assurance grand fond
d'investissement fond de pension
diverses et variés et puis
l'investisseur en bloc par public
autrement dit Action Logement et cdch
donc quatre acheteurs
entre juin 22 et grosso modo janvier 23
TR des qu ont totalement disparu pour
les raisons qu'on a évoqué RER de crédit
taux d'intérêt pour les investisseurs
institutionnels type grande banque et
autres faites-vous le raisonnement
suivant j'ai été investisseur
institutionnel privé même si c une fille
à l'X logement on avait un modèle
économique privé chez in le pas un
modèle de bailleur social donc on payait
de l'IS on avait exactement comme le
frais gessina foncière ou comme le frais
AXA quand on achet un logement on avait
un besoin de rentabilité moyenné de
rentabilité locative donc ce que nous
rapporte versus qu'on a acheté le
logement de 372 % c'était notre norme en
dessous on se faisait très très mal
au-dessus c'était bien mais 372 c'était
la norme bon 372 avec des d'intérêt à 1
donc en réalité on gagnait 2,72 bon
quand vos taux passent à 4 ou à 5 ben
votre rentabilité demandé elle est plus
de 3,72 mais est 372 plus l'augmentation
des taux MO1 le taux d'intérêt que
j'avais avant maisons 3 de plus
672 ce qui veut dire que quand je dois
investir pour avoir 672 versus avant
3,72 il faut quasiment que le prix
divise par 2 pour passer de 3 à 6 si je
le retrouve sur le prix d'achat il faut
que le prix soit divisé par 2 ce qui
n'existe évidemment nulle part donc les
investisseurs institutionnels sont
partis en 3 semaines à la première
montée des taux et ils ne reviendront
pas si tôt parce que c'est absolument
pas rentable ou alors il faudrait que
nous promoteurs on divise pris par deux
ce qu'on ne sait évidemment pas faire à
l'heure où nous
parlons premier exemple du pourquoi
celui-là est parti le propriétaire
occupant pas de débat on le sait tous le
propriétaire investisseur particulier
pour lui-même bah c'est à peu près la
même chose l'au il a à peu près le même
type de raisonnement que celui que j'ai
eu c'est l'investisseur institutionnel
il y a plus de rentabilité quand il
achète donc il s'en va pour ce
propriétaire investisseur privé pardon
particulier il a en plus les conditions
de resserement de crédit qui s'applique
aussi dans ce cas de figure là donc il
est parti propriétaire occupant bah il
est parti pour les taux bien évidemment
donc il nous restait globalement que ce
qu'on appelle les contrats cycliques
c'est-à-dire Action Logement et cdsh
c'est sympathique d'avoir deux acheteurs
ils ont fait un super job mais c'est pas
durable donc ça c'est le constat de
situation auxquell nous avons été
confrontés
euh
j'attire votre attention sur le fait
que aujourd'hui le sujet principal
auquel nous sommes confronté c'est donc
cette pénurie d'acheteur
bon cette pénurie d'acheteur a conduit
également à une autre conséquence jamais
analysé me semble-t-il dans ce que je
vois dans ce que j'entends et de
pourtant c'est ce que je vis
principalement comme promoteur
immobilier c'est que ça a généré une
pinuie de fond propre chez
nous juste pour vous mettre les les les
les les les choses un peu pour vous
expliquer un tout petit peu comment ça
fonctionne de l'Intérieur euh un
promoteur quand il développe une
opération immobilière il va d'abord
acheter un terrain puis il va construire
des sous cette opération d'ensemble
terrain plus travaux on la met dans une
filiale qui s'appelle une
sscv et c'est cette filiale qui engage
en gros l'opération donc c elle qui paye
les travaux celle qui paye le terrain et
ce et cette filiale dédiée à l'opération
en règle générale elle s'endête à
hauteur grosso modo de 90 % du coû de
l'opération l'opération vaut 100
millions cette filiale va aller chercher
9 millions en crédit bancaire classique
ce crédit bancaire tient à peu près bien
c'est un peu plus compliqué un peu plus
difficile qu'avant mais sincèrement les
banques ont vraiment joué le jeu
là-dessus 9 %. ensuite nous promoteurs
maison m en gros on doit descendre 10 %
de vrai cash qu'on appelle les fonds
propres c'est quelque part l'apport
personnel que nous faisons nous dans une
opération c'est exactement
intellectuellement mê modèle donc on met
10 % de fonds propres ces fonds propres
d'où on les récupère on les récupère de
deux sources nos
ventes bah si je vends plus j'ai plus de
fond propre
ou si au lieu de solder une opération de
vendre une opération en 18 mois je la
vends en 36 ma remontée de fond propre
au lieu de pouvoir la faire en 18 mois
mais je la fais en 36 mois mécaniquement
donc assèchement de cette première
source de fond propre deuxième source de
fond propre sur des promoteurs comme
nous indépendants mais sur les gros
promoteurs c'est quand même à peu près
le même débat deuxième source pour
obtenir des fonds propres du crédit
corporate principalement en version
obligataire donc on fait des obligations
on récupère des fonds propres on les
investit dans les opérations et quand
l'opération est vendue on remonte les
fonds propres bon il y a plus 1 € de
crédit obligataire sur l'immobilier
terminé il y a plus rien on a eu nous le
cas on a remboursé notre obligation
parce qu'on a pas réussi à la renouveler
en général je prends une obligation je
la renouvelle pu ça conc un cycle
perpétuel de crédit en la matière nous
n'avons plus accès à l'obligataire pour
de l'immobilier l'obligataire c'est donc
pas du crédit bancaire c'est de l'appel
au marché qui veut nous prêter de
l'argent à tel et type de condition et
qui répondent les grandes compagnies
d'assurance des fonds de pension des
fonds de dettes des fonds de ce que vous
voulez qui prennent nos obligations qui
sont des remboursements comme vous le
savez en infin et non pas en crédit
amortissable comme nous le connaissons
en en particulier et donc j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que premier sujet
il y a plus de fonds propres s'il y a
pas de fond propre on développe pas
d'opération je vais pas vous donner des
chiffres parce qu'on est en audition
publique sur ce qui concerne ma société
mais quand même pour ce qui nous
concerne dans ce qu'on appelle le
développement nous avons notre
approvisionnement je vais expliquer le
concept pour mesurer bien les
conséquences on l'a divisé grosso modo
par 2 et
dem donc si je faisais 200 je fais
aujourd'hui grosso modo 75 c'est ça
l'échelle très concrètement ça veut dire
quoi le cycle d'une opération
immobilière c'est
1 je signe une promesse de vente sur un
terrain j'ai négocié pendant un an un an
et demi pour quel prix quel machin quel
bidule à quelle condition je signe une
promesse de vente sur un terrain une
promesse de ventere ça signifie que
l'acheteur s'engage à vendre et moi je
m'engage à acheter avec des conditions
suspensives et ces conditions
suspensives c'est quoi en général le PC
bon une fois que j'ai signé ma promesse
de vente
j'ai grosso modo 2 ans pendant lequel je
vais déposer un PC l'obtenir le purger
faire ma
précmercialisation et ce n'est qu'à la
fin de ce cycle là que je vais
effectivement devant notaire acheter le
terrain et le
payer donc 2 ans entre la promesse et
l'achat effectif du terrain dès le
lendemain matin si ça se passe bien de
l'achat du terrain je commence mes
travaux 30 mois après le début de mes
travaux je livre l'opération
donc en gros 4 ans et demi 5 ans quand
tout se passe à peu près bien pour une
opération relativement simple mais qui
sont la majeur partie des opérations
B ce fameux approvisionnement donc le
début du
cycle c'est ça que nous avons passé pour
les années 23 24 25 qu'on a divisé par
2 c'est là-dessus où c'est pas le vrai
chiffre chez moi où on est passé 275
ce qui veut donc dire que
l'approvisionnement que j'ai 2023 c'est
les travaux de 25 et les livraisons de
28 mais si je fais pareil en 24 pareil
en 25 et c'est ça que j'ai présenté à
mes banques pour l'avenir et j'ai
évidemment pu voir à de multiples
reprises de nombreux de mes collègues
promoteurs ils ont tous fait pareil on
est tous en train d'abattre massivement
l'approvisionnement mais quand j'abats
l'approvisionnement de 24 c'est les
travaux 26 les livraisons
29 quand j'abat le 25 c'est le 27 pour
le 30 et donc ce que j'ai présenté à mes
banques pour 23 24 25 23 ét réalisé
comme prévu 24 25 sur ces TR années là
j'ai abattu globalement mon prévisionnel
de 2 et demi tous les promoteurs font
pareil ce que je veux vous dire par là
c'est que la baisse de prod que l'on
voit aujourd'hui les mises en chantier
ou les livraisons d'aujourd'hui ce n'est
rien par rapport à ce qu'on va avoir
dans 2
ans mécaniquement ce que je ne lance pas
aujourd'hui je ne le relancerai pas le
24 le 25 c'est de années paumées en la
matière et pour que je relance
c'estàdire pour que je
réappuie sur le développement que
j'essaie de trouver des terrains il va
falloir que je sois rassuré sur les
fonds propres et rassur faire les ventes
sur les deux boutons les fonds propres
et les ventes pour les fonds propres
première préconisation et je vais
essayer d'accélérer première
préconisation sur les fonds
propres qui va rentrer dans une logique
globale de préconisation que je vais
vous vous suggérer c'est de créer un
fond de fond propre par public je
m'explique première premier schéma
général je vais
essayer je crois avoir compris que le
gouvernement ne souhaitait plus beaucoup
mettre d'argent dans le secteur du
logement entre nous je peux un peu
l'entendre parce que les politiques du
logement d'un gouvernement sur le plan
fiscal c'est du soutien à la
demande le Pinel c'est du soutien à la
demande le prêt à zé c'est du soutien à
la demande tout ça c'est du soutien à la
demande soutenir la la demande quand on
est dans pénuie
d'offre économiquement la conséquence ça
fait monter les prix c'est mécanique
quand j'ai un problème d'offre quand
j'ai pas assez d'offre si je soutiens la
demande ben j'écarte encore plus l'un et
l'autre donc ça ne peut pas fonctionner
économiquement mais il se trouve que le
secteur des promoteurs immobiliers
fonctionne comme ça depuis 40 ans depuis
40 ans on est subventionné sur une
politique de la demande Pinel Prato zé
quel que soit leur nom ça existe depuis
40 ans sincèrement je pense que de ce
point de vue là sur le plan purement
économique je peux entendre le
gouvernementand je met ma casquette de
promoteur je m'étrangle évidemment parce
que c'était absolument indispensable
pour nous donc tout ce que je vais
essayer de vous proposer va partir d'une
double logique première logique on
arrête la demande et on repasse à
l'offre deuxème logique on arrête les
subs et on passe à l'investissement
puisque le prêt à tô zéro ou le Pinel
c'est de la subvention ça ne rapporte
pas un EUR à l'état pas 1 € je mets tous
les ans x milliards et je ne revois pas
la couleur de ces
milliards or il me semble que sur le
plan économique on peut avoir une
politique du logement qui soit une
politique d'investissement c'est-à-dire
qu'il produisent du logement et qui
rapportent de l'argent à l'état premier
exemple ce fond de fond propre ce fond
de fond propre c'est quoi vous rappelle
les chiffres 10 % sur une opération de
fonds propres en besoin si j'ai un une
institution publique la caise des
dépôts la BPI je sais pas qui peu
importe qui met 500 millions d'euros ou
même l'État à la limite je suis pas sûr
qu'il aurait le droit mais qui met 500
millions d'euros de fond
propre ça veut dire qu'il génère 5
milliards d'euros d'opération puisqu'on
est à 10 % de fond propre donc il aura
500 millions d'un côté 4 milliards 5 de
crédit de l'autre pour faire des
opérations immobilières ça commence à
être des grosses masses et cet argent là
c'est une obligation donc en fait
quelque part le par public se substitue
au secteur financier défaillant sur
l'immobilier l'état fait des obligues
auprès d'un promoteur ou
rentre à la limite comme actionnaire
dans une opération pour faire les fonds
propres de
l'opération cet argent là lui donc
remboursé avec un taux d'intérêt à 5 6
ou 7 donc non seulement c'est pas une
sub mais un investissement parce que
l'argent est remboursé mais il rapporte
des sous à celui qui a mis l'argent donc
l'ÉE idée c'est bien de se dire on
arrête de subventionner le secteur et on
part sur une politique d'investissement
où quand je mets 1 € ben j'en retire à
la fin 1,1 1,2 j'en sais rien et je
gagne de l'argent non seulement je suis
remboursé mais en plus je gagne des sous
bon donc ça c'est un fond de fonds
propre qui est une première mesure me
semble-t-il pour essayer de solutionner
la question des fonds propres qu'on a
évoqué mais j'ai évoqué qu'on avait un
problème à l'entrée les fonds propres
mais un problème à la sortie de la vente
donc il faut également si on veut que
nous promoteurs nous relancions la
machine qu'on puisse
vendre pour pouvoir vendre il nous faut
des acheteurs une la palissade mais
c'est une
réalité les acheteurs si on regarde un
peu vers quel type d'acheteur on peut
s'adresser l'acheteur particulier et
celui auquel on est tous le plus
attachés parce que c'est ce qui fait
l'accession à la propriété aujourd'hui
l'acheteur particulier il a les T inêt
élevé et des conditions de crédit
complètement
ubuesque pour que son parcours lui soit
simplifié les taux d'intérêt ça dépend
pas de nous on fera rien et avoir une
politique de l'État qui consisterait à
subventionner pour refaire baisser les
taux de fê me paraît absurde sur le plan
économique et en plus excessivement
coûteuse donc je me dis comment on fait
pour essayer d'assouplir les conditions
de crédit peut-être en inventant le
crédit
immobilier en tout cas en créant de
nouvelles formes de crédit
immobilier Vous avez tout en tête un
produit qui a été créé il y a quelques
années qui s'appelle le
BRS qui a un avantage extraordinaire
c'est que c'est un démembrement de
propriété entre le foncier et le bâti
outil superbe peut-être que ça limite
c'est que comme il est sous plafond de
ressources type SRU mais il s'adresse à
une population et c'est génial pour eux
c'est indispensable de le conserver qui
est peut-être un peu trop limitative
donc avoir demain du BRI en
intermédiaire voit du BRL en libre avec
cette fois-ci des offices fonciers
solidaires en I ou en L qui Contin
continuent à séparer les deux me
paraîtrait une bonne chose mais on peut
développer d'autres formes de
démembrement de propriété je vous donne
un exemple l'accession
progressive l'accession progressive
c'est quoi bah en gros sur une base de
du droit de l'indivision droit qui
existe l'équivalent de l'Office foncier
qu'on évoqué tout à l'heur va acheter 50
% du logement moi accédant à la
propriété j'achète 50 % du logement je
paye un loyer pour les 50 % qu' acheté
l'Office foncier solidaire ou pas
solidaire d'ailleurs et évidemment si 5
ans après malheureusement pour elle ma
grand-mère décède et que j'érite ou si
j'ai une carrière professionnelle qui
est venue positivement je peux racheter
les 50 % restants donc en gros j'habite
bien dans le logement je loue 50 % du
logement j'ai acheté 50 % du logement
l'avantage c'est qu'évidemment comme
j'ai une partie locative dans le bien
que
j'occupe et que je n'ai que 50 % d'achat
ça a deux conséquences un je solvabilise
le client parce qu'au lieu d'avoir un
taux d'intérêt à 5 % ou à 4 % sur 100 %
de la taille sur 100 % du logement je ne
l'ai que sur 50 % donc évidemment je
suis largement solvabilisé je pay un
loyer à côté mais sur ce loyer j'ai pas
ces taux d'intérêt deè élément positif
comme j'ai 50 % du logement
exclusivement en achat le taux de 35%
d'endettement évidemment je passe
dessous beaucoup plus facilement parce
que j'ai pas acheté j'ai bien besoin
d'un 40 m car pour vivre mais je n'ai
acheté que 20 m m² donc je paye des
intérêts sur 20 m² mais comme je n'ai
que 20 m² en achat bah trop de 35 % je
suis largement en dessous assez vite
voilà un exemple deuxième exemple
démembrement cette fois-ci en plus
classique nu propriété usufruit c'est le
même idée donc je passe vite
dessus l'Office quelconque foncier x ou
y achète
l'usufruit moi accédant à la propriété
j'achète la nu propriété grosso modo
c'est à peu près les mêmes valeurs 60 40
en fonction de la durée du contrat un
contrat de démembrement de la propriété
comment ça marche vous le connaissez
comme moi ça dure 18 ans pendant 18 ans
je pay un loyer d'un côté et j'ai acheté
la nu propriété de l'autre et puis à la
fin des 18 ans j'ai la complétude de la
propriété qui me revient bah là c'est ça
vous l'appliquez pour un particulier
l'Office foncier achète l'usufrit moi
accéd dans la propriété j'acète la nu
propriété je loue l'usuf fruit à
l'office X ou Y et au bout de 20 ans je
suis propriétaire des deux et là encore
même chose je n'ai un crédit que sur la
moitié donc je suis solvabilisé et je
nai un crédit que sur la moitié donc je
passe sous le taux de 35 %. et je pense
que c'est en démultipliant 3 4 5 produit
de ce type là pas un seul continuons le
BRS faisons le BRI faisons le BRL
faisons l'indivision faisons tout ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer à l'instant pour
que on a 5 si produits à la main
distribués par les banques qui
permettent grosso modo de répondre à
différents types d'attentees de clients
euh et l'idée c'est de se dire que le
BRS c'est génial mais si j'ai que le BRS
j'en feraai 3000 par an si j'invente
quatre ou cinq produits je vais créer un
vrai marché qui va vraiment répondre à
la demande tout ce qu'on vient d'évoquer
demande 0 € d'argent public et zéro loi
l'indivision ça existe le démembrement
de propriété ça existe il faut de
l'impulsion politique vis-à-vis des
banques et des assureurs parce que c'est
ça qui va être le plus compliqué je
pense il faut d'abord de l'impulsion
politique c'est tout pas besoin d'un €
pas besoin d'une loi un tout petit peu
parce qu'il peut y avoir un peu de
frottement fiscaux un peu de frottement
juridique a sûrement deux trois trucs à
nettoyer mais sincèrement ça a pas
besoin de grand-chose et donc là c'est
pour s'ouvrir un nouveau marché quelque
part avec des nouvelles formes de crédit
immobilier on pourrait parler du crédit
immobilier Infiné je pas si vous parle
le modèle suisse grosso modo qui
consiste à dire que j'emprunte 300000 €
je rembourse classiquement mes intérêts
tous les mois je rembourse classiquement
200000 des 300000 par exemple tous les
mois du capital et puis le Infiné le
principe c'est que j'ai une dernière
mensualité qui prend 100000 balles par
exemple ce qui veut dire que vous faites
évidemment baisser les remboursement
mensuel bon il y a un petit risque à la
fin c'est certain comment vous
solutionnez ce risque là B vous peut y
avoir plein d'idées c'est que l'idée que
la qutité du infin soit à peu près la
valeur du foncier comme ça j'ai une
assurance de quelque chose puis vous
pouvez dem dire aux banques serait
peut-être malin de faire un cré pas un
crédit de faire en plus du crédit Infiné
de l'associé à une épne retraite qui
permett au moment où en gros où j'ai mon
remboursement Infiné à 15 ans Ben que
j'ai à peu près la même sonne sur une
épamme retraite pour garantir le système
et éviter les risques systémiques bon
mais donc il y a plein de choses à
inventer en la matière c'est juste du
jus de cerveau pour inventer des
modalités juridiques et ensuite et de
l'impulsion politique pour les vendre à
des gens donc le crédit immobilier me
semble un enjeu absolument déterminant
en la matière trème élément pour les
acheteurs toujours on a je vousoula
évoquer deux acheteurs aujourd'hui par
publicu Action Logement
cdch peut-être qu'on peut en créer
d'autres et là encore dans une politique
d'investissement si on doit mettre de
l'argent quelque part pourrait très bien
imaginer des foncières par publici c'est
ce qu'a annoncé en partie madame borne
madame la Première ministre ellisabeth
BN lorsqu'elle a annoncé je sais pas si
vous souvenez 1 milliard bah grosso modo
c'était 250 millions d'euros de l'État
250 millions d'Uros de la CAE des dépôt
et puis 500 millions qui devent aller
chercher dans le privé j'espère qu'ils
vont les trouver pour avoir en gros une
foncière c'est-à-dire un outil qui
achète qui a 1 milliard d'euros qui
achète des logements en en général
plutôt en logement intermédiaire quel
est l'intérêt de ce modèle là c'est que
évidemment pour nous ça nous fait des
acheteurs en plus mais là encore le
milliard qui est mis par les uns et par
les autres il est rentable parce qu'en
face du milliard j'ai un actif quand
l'État fait un Pinel ou un préateau zéro
il a pas d'actif en face il a rien là je
vais acheter avec 10000 logements je
serai propriétaire de 10000 logements je
vais toucher 10000 loyers puis au bout
de 20 ans si je veux revendre les 10000
logements je revendrai les 10000
logements j'ai un actif économiquement
évidemment ça change tout et il me
semble d'ailleurs que les grandes
collectivités locales pourraient
imaginer ce type de modèle aussi les
grandes collectivités locales pourrait
demain s'imaginer à 10 mairie plus le
département monter des foncières locales
pour effectivement acheter des logements
en être propriétaire les mettre sur le
marché locatif donc garder les
attributions locatives qui vont avec ce
qui est souvent un intérêt non
négligeable pour les collectivités
locales euh qui permettrait là encore
d'avoir de diversifier les acheteurs
parapu toujours dans cette logique
d'investissement là encore là on met de
l'argent public mais c'est un argent
public qui va être rentable parce que
j'ai un actif qui est en face j'ai un
loyer j'ai une capacité de revente et
j'ai une rentabilité locative elle sera
petite la rentabilité elle sera 3 4 %.
mais une rentabilité locative ce n'est
strictement pas la même chose qu'une
subvention où là quand je mets 100
millions d'euros ou 1 milliard dans une
subvention jamais je ne retrouve le
milliard là je mets mon milliard et j'ai
un actif en face donc une rentabilité
locative économiquement c'est évidemment
tout à fait différent
euh peut-être et je vais je vais essayer
d'accélérer un tout petit peu vous citez
deux deux autres idées qui sont un peu
dans le même dans la même nature
un le financement du logement locatif
social
euh ayez en tête que là encore si je
raison en
d'actif nous avons 5 millions de
logements sociaux en France un peu plus
5,1 si je dis pas de bêtises si je mets
le logement à 100000 € Le
logement ça fait 500 milliards d'euros
d'actif 500 milliards d'euros d'actif
les bailleurs sociés sociaux français
sont riches de 500 milliards d'euros de
patrimoine
immobilier c'est phénoménal comme volume
financier sauf que cet argent nexiste
de fait dans leur bilan pourquoi parce
que les baurs sociau sont
comptablement ce qu'on appelle la VNC
valeur n comptable autrement dit le
logement 4
ans
par rit il vaut quel chose prière ch on
a des volumes d'actif
consid deè élément
ette valeurra
d'actif
c'est bien d'avoir de l'argent
potentiellement sur un bilan encore
faut-il qu'il estit ce qu'on appelle de
la liquidité si je peux jamais le vendre
j'ai bien avoir j'ai BO avoir 500
milliards ça me sert à rien d'avoir 500
milliards la liquidité que nous avons
essayé les uns et les autres depuis
longtemps c'est la vente au locataire ça
marche pas les bailleurs sociaux sont
contre je peux les comprendre parce que
il faut créer de la copro parce que et
cetera et là où il
faudrait avoir de l'argent pour produire
dans les zones très tendues c'est là où
il faut pas vendre parce que vendre un
logement social à Nice ou à Paris quand
il en a pas beaucoup et qu' a beaucoup
de demande c'est un peu absurde donc ce
modèle là de l'Avent unité que j'ai
promu comme d'autres sincèrement il
marche pas et dans beaucoup de cas de
figure il est pas malin en plus la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est qu'il
d'utes faç de vendre oui faç de vendre
on pourrait très bien créer une foncière
sociale
sousr qui donc acheter je prends un
exemple je ne sais pas comment s'appelle
le bailleur social de
betune pas de Cal habita par exemple ou
Nice
habita code d'Azur habita pardon et chez
vous je ne sais pas comment il s'appelle
voilà mais je suis pas sûr que la
tension soit tout à fait la
même que celle de
Nice bon mais je vais prendre un exemple
plus neutre complètement neutre Paris
Habitat tout à fait neutre par rapport à
tous les trois mais c'est pas celui qui
a le moins de problématique par rapport
à ce qu'on évoque bon l'idée la suivante
Paris Habitat vend dit n'importe quoi
5000 logements à la foncière sociale
sous livra que j'ai évoqué et donc ça
veut dire quoi sous livra que la
foncière sociale va prendre un emprunt
de 40 ans ou de 50 ans auprès de la
Caisse dépôt classique du livra pour
s'acheter les 5000 logements les 5000 à
Paris ça vaut de 2 3 milliards d'euros
avec ces de ou 3 milliards d'euros Paris
Habitat peut construire des logements
massivement bon prier point deè
élément cette foncière elle n'a qu'un
rôle de détention elle va rembourser son
crédit puisque c'est elle qui va
récupérer le loyer normal est
propriétaire par contre cette foncière
peut passer un contrat de gestion
locative à Paris Habitat en disant à
Paris Habitat c'est toi qui continue à
gérer meble c'est toi qui continue à
t'occuper des locataires pour
rémunération de ce service je te donne 5
% du loyer et c'est toi qui conserve les
attributions
locatives en fait on fait tourner le
patrimoine quand vous faites l'analyse
du cycle de vie d'un logement un
logement l'é voqua tout à l'heure a une
durée de vie de 80
années en général un français reste
propriétaire de son bien immobilier
pendant 8 ans donc ça veut dire grosso
modo qu'un logement dans sa vie va avoir
10 ventes et reventes donc il va générer
10 crédits un crédit en moyenne tous les
8 ans et cetera et cetera dans le monde
entier ça se passe comme ça sauf dans le
logement social français où on ne vend
jamais rien jamais si on veut éviter le
côté risque de privatisation qui est un
vrai risque que je peux entendre c'est
la raison pour laquelle je ne propose
pas que ce soit des institutionnel privé
qui achète ça
mais un autre bailleur social qui
s'appellera une foncière sociale qui
n'aura qu'une chose à faire je fais un
crédit à la Caisse des dépôts et
j'encaisse mes loyers point tout le
reste on laisse au bailleurvendeur mais
qui a récupéré beaucoup de cash pour
investir ça c'est un modèle du
financement du logement social qui l'a
encore de demande 0 € d'argent public 0
€ d'argent public qui
maintient la gestion locative de Paris
Habitat les attributions à Paris Habitat
et qui donne un paquet de cash à Paris
Habitat pour lancer de nouveaux
programmes immobilier le tout en restant
dans la sphère sociale c'est du
refinancement d'opération euh plutôt que
d'avoir des logements qui sont jamais
refinancés ben on les refinance tous les
ans enfin dernier point
euh dans les mesures moi je pense qu'il
y en a une qui me paraît indispensable
sur les sujets qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est euh lié au
foncier c'est une matière première on l'
évoqué absolument déterminante pour les
années qui viennent plus que jamais moi
à titre
personnel je commence de plus en plus à
me dire que la détention publique du
foncier bah c'est peut-être pas
complètement stupide en tout cas qu'il
faut l'accentuer il faut évidemment pas
exproprier toute la France personne
n'urait les moyens de le faire et ce
serait stupide mais quand un terrain se
libère il est un peu important et cetera
que l'État et les moyens l'État ou des
agents publics de l'acheter de continuer
tenir et de le remettre sur le marché un
bail anfitotique de 99 ans qui permet de
sécuriser financièrement l'opération
paraî ça pour y arriver je ne vois qu'un
seul outil les établissements public
fonciers
euh ils sont de mon point de vue
sousdotés il faut faire x 4 ou x 5 dans
leur budget d'investissement et là
encore toujours la même logique comme
pour le bailleur social comme pour les
fonds propre comme pour la foncière
comme pour tout ce que vous voulez même
chose si je mets 1 milliard sur du
foncier ben j'ai 1 milliard d'actif
puisque j'ai acheté le terrain de
l'autre et quand je le revends en B en
fitéotique et ben je le revends un
milliard mais j'en garde la détention et
j'ai maximisé la détention publique du
foncier si on reste sur des fonciers qui
passent d'un privé à un autre privé ou
malheureusement souvent d'une
collectivité locale ou d'une esppl ou
toute forme de débrement on bascule dans
la spéculation foncière parce qu'on fait
tous derrière des appels d'offrees et
quand je fais un appel d'offre avec
enchère publique sur sur le le
bah tous les promoteurs bah qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils se r encher les un avec
les autres donc on est dans une machine
qui fait mécaniquement monter le prix du
foncier les seuls qui ne le font pas
c'est les EPF raison pour laquelle il
faut mettre le paquet d'argent sur les
EPF là encore de l'argent en
investissement pas en sub j'aurais bien
un actif en face et j'aurais une
rentabilitéet actif en face mais pour
limiter la spéculation foncière et avoir
durablement de la propriété foncière
voilà très vite pas trop vite d'ailleurs
j'ai été beaucoup trop trop long j'en
suis désolé juste un dernier mot sur une
question que vous avez deux questions
vous avez posé auquell je n'ai pas
répondu le lli
SRU en tant que promoteur j'applaudis
parce qu'évidemment c'est ça ouvre les
vannes de l'accord des collectivités
locales sur le lli donc en tant que
promoteur j'applaudis tout de suite
ayant eu d'autres casquettes j'aurais un
peu plus de nuance par rapport à ça et
j'aurais peut-être une
préconisation qui consisterait à dire
qu' ne faut pas me semble-t-il
l'intégrer dans le taux SRU mais qu'il
faut le neutraliser VO le lli
aujourd'hui est calculé comme du
logement privé donc on désavantage le
lli aujourd'hui je fais pas de lli parce
que ça me pose un problème avec mon t
SRU mécaniquement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la proposition qui est faite
c'est de le mettre dans le tau SRU bah
là je vais pénaliser le logement social
donc aujourd'hui si je mets dans le taux
SRU je p pénalise le social si je le
laisse comme il est je pénalise le
logement intermédiaire au bénéfice du
logement libre ben neutraliser on le met
plus dans le décompte de la SRU ce qui
est assez
cohérent j'ai du logement social il faut
un avantage j'ai du logement libre bah
je le désavantage un peu avec les taux
SRU et puis l'intermédiaire qui est
entre les deux et ben je le neutralise
entre les deux ni SRU ni avantage à su
ni inconvénient à serue et ça me paraît
un bon équilibre entre
les différentes entre guillemets options
que nous avons sur la table est-ce que
les maires sont un problème par rapport
au PSC et par au PLU la réponse est oui
alors c'est pas les maires c'est les
maires porte-parole de leurs concitoyens
pas en tant que tel nos concitoyens sont
averses à la production logement bon
l'acceptabilité je sais pas si elle a
existé mais en tout cas elle existe de
moins en moins je pense qu'il faut
passer outre mais c'est excessivement
compliqué pour un ma en zone tendue de
passer outre outre et je pense qu'il
faut passer outre parce que seul
l'autorité publique que nous
représentons en tant que maire peut
avoir un regard d'intérêt général à 20
ans alors que nos concitoyens et c'est
normal ils ont un regard à demain matin
je veux pas de chantier devant chez moi
j'en veux bien chez le voisin mais pas
devant chez moi et donc il faut quelque
part avoir cet élément là parce
qu'effectivement de façon
systématique je crois que le chiffre est
sorti SMAP il était intéressant on
sature à hauteur de 65 % le
PLU j'ai un PLU qui autorise
8 étages ben j'en fais 6 je perds 35 %
de la capacité sur je le rappelle un
texte le PLU qui a été fait par la
mairie c'est pas un texte qui est fait
par une autorité extérieure c'est un
texte fait par la mairie la mairie fait
un texte elle ne l'applique
pas je pense sincèrement qu'il y a un
pépin par rapport à ça et oui
aujourd'hui on ne sature pas les
plu beaucoup plus que le refus de PC qui
existe mais le refus de PC fait perdre
du temps de l'argent mais à un moment ou
un autre je vais l'avoir je vais en
faire TR ça va me coûter des ronds je
vais perdre 3 ans pour le faire mais je
vaisabandonner 30 % donc je vais quand
même paumer un paquet d'opération mais à
un moment un autre l'opération reviendra
bon quand je paume mes 35 % de
constructif
par rapport au PLU c'est paumé pour 80
ans les deux étages que je n'ai pas
fait je ne les ferai jamais je les paume
80 ans je fais 4 au lieu de faire 6 et
ben j'ai paé deages pendant 8
ans
j'arrête merci beaucoup bon voilà je
m'attendais à ce que bien évidemment
cette audition soit combien riche et for
force de proposition pour le moins on
n'est pas déçu on a peu de temps parce
qu'on a une autre audition si rapidement
mais très rapidement l'une et l'autre
vous avez une ou deux questions à poser
à monsieur le ministre je vous laisse la
parole mais le plus rapidement possible
dans les questions alors moi ça va pas
être une des questions parce que
vraiment tout ce que j'avais vous avez
répondu par anticipation à tout ce que
j'avais je voulais vraiment vous
remercier pour pour la qualité de de ces
propositions sur tous les niveaux en
plus comme enfin un petit peu comme une
vision un peu générale votre position
d'ancien ministre comme maire aussi moi
j'ai été maire aussi d'une commune les
Hautes Pyrénées il y a des zones très
très tendudes dans les Hautes Pyrénées
il y a des près des stations de ski il y
a des zones très très tendues où en plus
on a peu de fonciers où on peut pas
construire et où les prix s'envolent et
on peut plus loger ni les per ni les
salariés ni les saisonniers c'est ça
devient très compliqué et puis aussi par
votre activité de promoteur très
intéressant parce que vous allez prendre
les deux casquettes aussi donc merci
beaucoup
merci rapidement bien forcément je vais
vous remercier également euh de
questions très courtes un euh vous avez
je vais je vais pas reposer le contexte
ni rien est-ce que le pour vous le
modèle de la maison individuelle est un
modèle mort vous avez évoqué la
verticalité et C je je reviens pas sur
encore une fois une explication mais
cette première question et puis une
deuxième question vous avez très bien
exprimé
la difficulté d'avoir une politique
globale conttenu de des des différences
territoriales est-ce qu'à
aujourd'hui notre la gouvernance de la
politique du logement et t'adapter alors
c'est une question qui peut paraître
courte avec peut-être une grande réponse
mais juste encore une fois de façon très
synthétique votre sur la
gouvernance je pense être un acteur
assez averti je suis maire j'ai été
ministre et cetera et cetera je suis
incapable d'expliquer à une classe de 3e
comment marche la gouvernance du
logement en France et plus
particulièrement en Île de France je
suis incapable de l'expliquer à une
classe de 3e impossible je sais pas
faire mais je plaisante pas c'est pas
juste une une boutade je serais incable
de dire qui est responsable de qui en la
matière donc c'est
illisible incompréhensible et nous
professionnels en fonction des cas on
sait pas très bien à qui on s'adresse
c'est pas c'est vraiment pas d'une
clarté absolue donc j'ai un vrai
problème par rapport à ça petite incise
faut-il pourant décentralis qui peutêtre
la
conséquence j'avoue une forme
d'inquiétude je suis
m comme j'ai plutôt le sentiment
aujourd'hui que les collectivités
locales sont pas qui le plus le
champignon pour produire tout le pouvoir
à ce qui freent intelluellement ça que
je veux dire je sais pas où on pe
mettilleurs et je sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'on peut mettre en échange de la
décentralisation qui sera effectivement
vra élément de simplification il y a un
vrai élément de lisibilité on file tout
à tel rang de collectivité locale et il
se démerd ça me va très bien comme
modèle mais il faut qu'on échange de ça
quelque part on a une assurance que
c'est pas trois fois plus de frein sur
l'ensemble des projets immobiliers bon
deuxè
question la maison individuelle est-elle
morte la maison individuelle dans le
sens un terrain 1000 m car et 75 m car
construit au sol sur deux étages pour
faire 150 maart
oui mort j'en sais rien il y aura
toujours un peu mais en tout cas il faut
éloigner cet élément là de nos rêves
parce que la surconsommation foncière
est en grande partie l à ça quand vous
regardez la consommation foncière par
typologie de logement on en bouffe
beaucoup avec ça là où je fis une énorme
nuance c'est que c'est pas la fin de la
maison individuelle quand vous prenez
les règles de densité qu' existe
aujourd'hui l'univers du monde social
des années 60 70 avec des nappes de
parking à plat et des nappes d'espace
vert à plat entre deux tours consomme
beaucoup plus de
fonciers qu'un
centrebourg d'un d'une commune avec des
maisons individuelles si vous êtes sur
le modèle des maisons dites en bande
c'est-à-dire des maisons de ville où
j'ai un petit jardin de 50 m² derrière
ou 60 m² comme on l'a dans le nord par
exemple les modèles des maisons ouvrè du
temps ça marche super bien et c'est très
dense j'ai les maisons à coller je suis
bien chez moi j'ai mon petit jardin
derrière alors j'ai pas 1000 m car de
jardin don TAAC ok mais je peux en faire
et c'est très dense et c'est beaucoup
plus dense que l'habitat social donc
c'est pas mort du tout à condition
effectivement qu'on ripe vers ce modèle
là me
semble-t-il merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre de cette audition voilà merci
du fond du cœur merci beaucoup à vous
mesdame
n'était pas terminé mes collègues
continueront donc monsieur